a linked list is a common data structure
where elements are stored in a node the
node contains two key pieces of
information the element itself and
reference to the next node so in this
example the element here will be one and
then here's the reference to the next
note this arrows point to the two this
two is the element we're storing the
information to and the way this length
linking to the next node like arrays
linked lists can be used to implement
many other data structures linked lists
have some advantages and disadvantages
when compared to arrays traditionally
arrays are just have a fixed size and
linked lists have dynamic size so you
can just keep adding links and you don't
have to do anything differently
JavaScript kind of hides some of this
but when you create an array can only be
a fixed size also arrays have pretty
inefficient insertions and deletions
while linked lists are very efficient
search terms and deletions a benefit to
arrays are the random access which means
you can say you want something at index
five and you can instantly get the thing
at index five however with linked lists
if you want something at index five you
have to go through every element in the
linked list to get to index five and
then for arrays they may result on much
memory rot waste to make up for the fact
that arrays can only only be made at a
fixed size sometimes they will be
created a lot bigger than what you
really need to make sure you have enough
room for everything however in a linked
list because of the dynamic size there
is no wasted memory and then we have
really fast sequential access for raised
and slow for linked lists so every
linked list is gonna have a head so we
have this head pointer here that points
to the first node and then it's also
going to have a size so that's just the
amount of note so in this example here
the size will be three and you can see
each node points to the next node in the
last node it just points to null because
there is no next node so if you look at
the code over here we start with the
head of null because we don't have a
head yet and the length is going to be
zero and the linked list is made up of
nodes so here's how we're going to
create a node we pass in an element and
this element set to element this
next is set to null so this not element
in the picture is the info and this that
next in the picture is the link so it
starts off just like the last element
where the link is pointed null next is
pointing to null then we just have a few
simple functions this size just returns
a link and this the head just returns
the head and here's the add function
whatever we're going to pass in to the
linked list is gonna be the element so
you're gonna add the element and then
we're gonna create a new node with that
element so after you pass in the element
and it creates this new node the element
of the node is set to the element you
passed in but the next of the node is
set to null so if head equals null that
means there are no nodes in the linked
list yet so we just set the head to
equal the node and at that point there
just be one node in the linked list and
the head would be pointed that first
node else that means there's more than
one element list we're gonna set the
current node to equal the head and let's
add a var in front of here so this just
means that we're gonna start at the head
node which you always have to do
whenever you're doing anything to a
linked list you start the beginning and
then you to go through each item in the
list while current node dot next that
means while there is a current door next
while current node dot next does not
equal null you can see at the end
remember the link equals current node
next so at the end it equals null so
before the end of the list the current
node next which would be the link does
not equal null if equals the next node
so this just means while there is a next
node current node equals current node
next so that's just a way to hop from
node to node on the list once there is
no current node next that means we're at
the end of the list the end of the list
is where we want to add the element that
we're adding now we'll set current node
next to equal the node once we get to
the last node in the list we'll set the
Curnow debt necks or this link to equal
the new node we added instead of null
and we just increment the length the
remove method takes an element and
searches the linked list to find and
remove the node containing that element
so you're passing the element that you
want to remove and we always start at
the head current node equals head and
then we also need to know the previous
node when you're gonna remove something
so if the current node that element
equals element if current node element
equals element well that just means that
the head node in the element we're
trying to remove so if we're trying to
remove the head node we just have to set
the head to current node that next so
the head pointer will be pointing to the
next node if the head node is not the
node we're looking for we go to the else
so else while current node to element is
not equal known element basically while
the node Ron does not equal the node
we're searching for previous node is
gonna equal the current node I guess
that we have to keep track to the
previous node and in the current node is
going to equal current node next which
just means we're gonna keep going
through this while loop and keep jumping
to the next note on the list until we
find the node we're looking for let's
let's say it's this second note on this
example here we're gonna set previous
node next to equal current node done
next if we're trying to remove this
second node we're gonna set previous
node dot next so the previous node that
next would be the first node so there'll
be the link the link is now going to not
point to the current node the link is
going to point to the current node dot
next we would skip over that node and
point to the current node next right
here and that's how a node would be
deleted from the linked list and then we
just decrement the link now here's
another quick function is empty return
link equals equals equals zero so if the
length equals zero we're going to return
true if it doesn't equal zero we're
gonna return false and you may want to
know the index of a specific element so
we're just gonna have to hop from node
to node until we find that element and
then return that index so current node
is gonna equal head start at the
beginning and next is gonna start at
negative one and so Wow
that means while there is a current node
while it's not null we're gonna
increment the index so at this point we
start the beginning we've increment the
index so where the index is now is 0 so
if current node that element equals
element return index so if the first
element which would be this info equals
what we pass in up here we're gonna
return the index so if instead in the
head node we're gonna return the index 0
if not current node equals current node
next and then we continue doing this
while loop and just hop from node to
node and then then we're gonna
eventually be able to return the index
as we keep adding 1 to the index for
every time we do the while loop and if
we go through all the whole while loop
and don't find anything we're gonna
return negative 1 that just means the
element is not in the linked list so we
just found the index of an element now
we're going to find the element at and
index that's just the opposite you're
passing an index number and you're going
to return the element so we have current
node equals head count equals 0 and
here's the Wallow appear while count is
less than index that means we haven't
gotten to the index we're searching for
increment count and current node equals
current node next so that means we hop
to the next node so we're gonna keep
going through every node in the list
until count is not less than index that
means count equals index so we've
reached the right index so we can just
return current node that element yep
you're gonna pass in the index and
elements and add remember who you always
add to the end of the linked list but an
ADD at you can add in the middle of the
list so just like a ID we're gonna
create a new node with the element we
passed them and a current node is gonna
equal head we always start at the
beginning we need to keep track to the
previous node and the current index is
gonna equal 0 so if index is more than
length that means we pass in an index
that's way bigger than the actual length
of the linked list so we cannot add at
that index when we return false if index
equals 0 that means we're trying to add
the element to the head node so we'll
set node NX or no it is a node that we
just passed in so the next
is now gonna be the current node which
would be the current head node and then
we just set the head to equal the node
that we passed in else we don't want the
index to be the head node while current
index is less than index we're gonna go
through each index until we find the
correct index Soaker index increment
we're gonna set the previous node to
equal the current node so we wanna keep
track of the previous node the current
node is gonna equal current node next
we're gonna keep going through this
while loop until we find the correct
node so if we want to add a node as
index one or the second node on the list
once we get to that index we're gonna
set node next equal to current node so
or no dot next is the node we passed in
and we're gonna set that to equal the
current node which would be this index
right here then we have to set previous
node that next equals and note that
we're passing in and then we just
increment the length and the last
function I'm gonna talk about is remove
it now remove it and and at are very
similar a lot of the lines are the same
except we're not going to create a new
node the kernel is gonna be the head we
need a previous node the current index
is gonna be 0 here is a slightly
different thing if the index is less
than 0 or if the index is more than or
equal to length return null so we cannot
remove a negative index and we cannot
remove an index greater than the length
of the list if index equals 0 we're
trying to remove the head node so we
just set the head node to equal the
current node next so instead of the head
pointer point to this node right here
the head pointer is going to point to
the next node right here else this part
is just like the ad and we're just gonna
keep going through each element on the
list and once we find the element we
want to remove like let's say we're
removing this second element at index 1
we're going to set previous node that
next to equal current node dumb max
we're going to set the previous node
next or this link is going to point to
whatever was in the link to the current
node or so this link is going to point
to now this node right here and we're
going to completely take out this one
and then we
do linked - - and return the node that
we're removing and now we're just going
to quickly show an example of using the
linked list we're going to call the
linked list conga because a linked list
is kind of like a conga line and let me
bring up the console so we're gonna
create this new linked list we're gonna
add some items kitten puppy dog catfish
we're gonna show the size we're going to
remove the third item on the list so
we'll run them and see we're gonna
remove cat now let's copy this we're
gonna do element at then we'll try index
app and for the element we're gonna put
puppy look I mean index of so we remove
cat now we check the new element three
which is gonna be fish and the index of
puppy is gonna be one kitchen would be
zero copyist one and the size is four
well that's the linked list thanks for
watching my name is beau Carnes don't
forget to subscribe and remember use
your code for good